hello there this is Steve coffin to talk
about language learning we read a lot to
hear a lot about web 2.0 and how it's
going to influence language learning and
of course it will the main thing there
of course is to keep it simple and fun
and to not bring the teacher directed
complicated grammar based make work
interactive ideas of the professional
teachers into the web two point O
language learning space let's let the
learners decide what they want and I'm a
learner I'm not a teacher to me I like
things that are simple and fun I like my
little iPod shuffle I can take it
wherever I want I have it clipped on my
shirt I can listen to content that I've
just downloaded from my computer I have
collections in different languages
Russian Portuguese whatever i'm working
on it's fun and it's easy to do yes i
like it's small it's a bit like my
dental floss which has saved me
thousands of dollars and much pain
because it brought my gums back I was
told I wasn't flossing enough very
simple not expensive it works these are
all preferable to what teachers will do
if they are left to their own devices
I'll give you an example in Russian
here's a book making progress in Russia
for second-year students and you open up
a page here at random use of the
perfective aspect the perfective past
tense is used if a result has been
achieved and remains in force if the
action has taken place and has not been
annulled the perfective future is used
by the speaker if an action is intended
or expected to be completed the
perfective is used if the moment of
achieving the result is emphasized I
mean who can possibly remember that
stuff let alone understand it my
approach to Russian which is a
complicated language has a lot of
grammar in it is I listen I start
listening to easy things and I gradually
go to more difficult things and of
course I'm lucky in that with link I can
start with
I content items that are at my
vocabulary level or that are very very
simple some cases that where I have a
translation I listen I save words and
phrases I get to use to it I listen to
the when i first started 20 30 40 times
the point is it's all fun so the message
with web point 20 is we want to get a
lot of interaction we want the learners
to say what they want there may be
learners who want the detailed grammar
explanations personally I recommend
trying to avoid it until you have heard
a lot of the language enjoy stories in
the language and of course what we're
doing at link is we have our learners
giving us content in their own languages
talking about their daily experiences in
their own languages transcribing it
people are trying to learn that language
can download it and listen to it over
and over again maybe create something
back in their own language all of this
is fun language learning is fun language
learning need not be the tedious grammar
based exercise drill based you know you
got it wrong type of thing that we're
used to at school we have to take
language learning away from the school's
away from the textbooks away from the
teachers and give it back to the
learners and that's my message for today